so for this migration issue that you've
been focusing on more recently after
doing your documentary do you have
suggestions for how to improve
the entire situation from both sides of
america and people trying to get saved
it's funny funny you ask because i
didn't this is a documentary that i i
didn't have any defined conclusions at
the end i kind of leave it up to the
viewer
to to make up their mind
um
you i think you have to have a
consistency you people actually have to
know what your policies are because when
they don't they're willing to go on
this
i i compare the whole thing i filmed i
compared to hell i use like levels of
dante's inferno and different um
references to types of hell within
different cultures for all the names of
my chapters
because it was the only comparison i
could make
of what i witnessed there like you've
got tapachula stadium which is right
across from guatemala and it's like a
limbo people are there for months and
months and months and months on end just
sleeping under the hot sun sleeping
under trees they have no idea whether
they're going to be allowed to stay in
mexico they have no idea whether they're
going to be deported they have no idea
what's happening at all it's just this
like hellish limbo and then
they continue on the track and they
basically have to find traffickers you
can take uh
you can take a train up to
the u.s border called the beast it's
actually got three dames the the trade
the death train train de la burt or the
train of unknowns they have these three
horrifying
and people die all the time on there it
tends to be run by the zetas they'll
make you pay fees they'll rape you on
the train because you can't get off
there's no where you can go people will
go on the top of the train and get
knocked off by tree branches lose limbs
beneath the tracks and everything and
they take this death train you know flip
a coin just to get up to the border and
then find human traffickers and pay to
get across maybe get shot maybe get you
know kidnapped uh the state i was in
kamalipas interesting story um a lot of
migrants tend to get kidnapped by the
cartel in mexico because they're
nameless faceless people right if you
want to get rid of a crime or if you
want to commit a crime especially
something like rape or murder then rape
or murder someone who can't be tracked
or found
and that's that's going to be migrants
in i think it was 2011 right near where
we were staying they had the san
fernando massacres done by the cartel in
tomalipes there where they kidnapped 200
people off of passenger buses and took
them to
there's either like a field or a stadium
and gave them hammers knives and various
different weapons and made them all
fight to the death
why with the yeah
literally squid game in real life no
joke oh my gosh and
they the winner got to become a sicario
for their game so they had these 200
people like fight the death brutally in
what they could what was described by
police as gladiator style
matches and all the buses just showed up
in reynosa where i was staying empty
with like no one on them and just
luggage right and then they buried all
these people in mass graves that they
found later but this is this is like the
the risks and the lives of these
migrants who go through mexico
it's just like a reality that they take
that's horrifying i've been re-watching
game of thrones
i know just this is so loosely
associated
i regret that starting now but but
anyway it's violent right and i'm like
this isn't real like this can't
it's shocking to think uh a culture can
degenerate to that point
where where you can pit 200 people
against each other and then the winner
joins the gang
that's like so absurd for the average
person to even believe is possible or
like oh that would never happen here or
and
yeah it's i'm so torn about this
immigration issue because the people
trying to get in are people
that are suffering so badly right to to
risk all those things to try and bring
like them and their kids to some place
that isn't as scary like no wonder
people are trying to get in
this is what pisses me off sometimes and
i don't blame you for thinking it at all
because this is what people are told but
they're like oh they're trying to get
out of this situation that is so scary
like ninety percent of these people are
economic migrants they you're telling me
i'm naive
is that what you're saying lauren you're
not saying
you how could you know like no one's
telling anyone this it's not it's not
your fault um but like the sushiyate
where i went across um
to there's a little town i think it's
called chiapas
beautiful beautiful area any one of
these migrants coming from south america
could have stayed there in fact we
interviewed the mayor of this little
town across from associate and she said
they have hundreds thousands of migrants
come and stay in that little town and
they thrive there she's a really good
mayor too holy [ __ ] she just um when i
was there they were having a parade
because they had built uh
light posts all across the street to
stop crime because putting light in city
areas tends to reduce reduce crime
drastically so this was like her project
they're putting light posts all across
the town
gorgeous town of course you're not going
to have the same you know big living
that you could find in america but you'd
be safe you'd be safe if you stayed
there so when i see people oh i'm going
to drag my kid across the darian gap i'm
going to drag my kid on the beast you
know let them fall between the wheels
that i have a better chance of getting a
passport to america no for the most part
it isn't for safety no i don't believe
that some people for sure but most are
economic migrants and admit as much
you know what part of me is like i don't
oh
part of me i don't want to blame them
because they get told it's easier than
it actually is human traffickers tell
them that it's not going to be as
dangerous as they think it is so maybe
they do genuinely actually no i do think
a lot of them genuinely believe it's not
going to be this insane crazy
death trap of a trip so maybe it isn't
so much their fault but if they were
given the truth i think a lot more
people would stay in the southern safer
states of
mexico like chiapas and and make a life
there instead of
yeah taking this hell trip north